jarl wartooth with two swords
at lock town dog says you ever look back
at your day's twitter posts and think
there's something slightly off with your
gray matter
well joel only if you're the president
of the united states
hi i'm mayam bialik and this is
neuroscience support
[Music]
alexandria friesen at lexi friesen
asks at what point is a guy's frontal
lobe
fully developed with many question marks
i want to use this knowledge as a gauge
for when to give them a 17th
chance and when to just throw the whole
man away
well lexi the frontal lobe should be
developed
in the late teens or early 20s if we're
lucky
but sometimes by behavior it just seems
like it doesn't happen
i'd say if you're looking at a 17th
chance throw the whole man away
or woman d at bellicose van
says one thing that does bug me is this
thing called capgras syndrome
like how do you actually know that the
things around you haven't been replaced
with an exact copy
well d that's the point capgras syndrome
is a delusional psychiatric disorder
where you actually
believe that someone close to you is a
replica
and not the actual person it's a
very very very specific unusual
existential crisis of a disorder and the
fact is
you really don't know robin richardson
at robin underscore r underscore r says
can stendall syndrome kill you
well stendahl syndrome is a syndrome of
both physical and emotional features
typically when seeing something of
tremendous
beauty you have a rapid heartbeat you
can faint you can have hallucinations
robin i don't think it can kill you but
it sounds like you might be in love
enjoy truck man's ghost
at truckman's ghost says is it possible
to have katard syndrome
but like in a sexy liberating way well
i'm going to be as delicate as i can
right now considering that this is a
syndrome which is a delusion that you
are
dead or that your organs are liquefying
or
i'm going to go ahead and say no
dr baumuk kamdar at kamdar
underscore j asked does knowing how and
why a person behaves
as he behaves neuroscience absolve the
person of his actions and its subsequent
consequences
knowing how and why a person behaves is
extremely important in understanding
people's motivations
but it absolutely does not absolve the
person of
actions and consequences this is a
really really complicated
legal issue obviously and i think as our
understanding
of human motivation and behavior expands
and as our knowledge of
the brain and the mind expands we're
understanding more about
some principles of compassion um and i
think that's been sorely lacking from
the justice system especially when it
deals with people with
mental health challenges or
psychological or psychiatric conditions
the entity comma jim at
blood flu says neuroscience friends
hey how and why does the out breath
activate the parasympathetic nervous
system
what is the mechanism and what should i
read to understand it
let's say that you don't need to know
the mechanism unless you really really
want to in which case
i would honestly just google
parasympathetic nervous system
and you can read all about it but
doctors like dr sarno have talked a lot
about
de-escalating the agitation of the
nervous system
by lowering blood pressure and one of
the ways that we do this
is with deep exhalation there's a whole
vagal system of your nervous system and
the vagal system is responsible for
really acting as as the downer for your
system
it involves the brain it involves organs
in your body which all contribute to
heart rate and
blood constriction things like that and
those are the things that literally
increase your blood pressure and make
you feel that sense of agitation
so the exhalation stimulates the vagal
nerve and that whole system
which helps your entire body literally
slow down
there's also amazing meditation books
about breath
and i would look to those to see the
practical applications
of helping your parasympathetic nervous
system calm you down
snicket mcgee at snicket chan
asks is it possible to have chronic
fatigue syndrome as
a child a lot of people question
the actual diagnosis of chronic fatigue
syndrome it is a collection
of symptoms that get grouped into this
diagnosis and i'm not saying
i don't believe in it absolutely you can
have chronic fatigue syndrome and all of
those symptoms
as a child a hundred percent but also
from a clinical perspective you really
want to look to what are the other
factors in a child's environment that
are leading to those symptoms
there is a huge psychological
environmental component
to all of these kinds of diagnoses
whether in adults or children so i would
actually look to address those
first acron at apron
says is there a mask that is more
trigeminal neuralgia-friendly
i ask that every day i'm trying to not
put myself in pain
each time i need to buy something this
is a great question
the trigeminal nerve is a very special
nerve it's one of your cranial nerves
and some people are extremely sensitive
to
irritation of that nerve that is a thing
if anyone's ever had a migraine
and has felt your teeth and your nose
and your eye
hurt that's your trigeminal nerve
getting really really mad
i'm going to go ahead and say if that
mask is out there
you can probably find it i do not want
you to be in pain
every time you need to buy something or
just go back to the old school bandana
and make sure it comes all the way up to
your nose mikhail
at cracklechulo wants to know
guys any recommendations for someone who
has a sleep disorder
doesn't matter if it's medicine well i'm
sure that you've
searched other things that people do for
sleep disorders besides medicine and
i would recommend those things both as a
neuroscientist
and as a human meditating before bed i
know some people are like oh that's so
stupid
any meditation program that does guided
sleep meditations can be really really
helpful
in going to sleep if you have trouble
staying asleep
meditation will also help in lowering
your general
kind of need for your brain to process
actively at night
people do like melatonin which you can
take in safe supplements and that mimics
your body's
natural sleepy hormones a warm bath
before bed
is good because it actually heats you up
so your body compensates and
lowers your body temperature which is
what your body likes to go to sleep so
for those of you who like to get cozy
under the covers
there's a reason for that also just
general shout out
for psychotherapy or cognitive
behavioral therapy
a lot of those of us with sleep
disorders have underlying
things going on in our heads and our
lives that can interfere with sleep
also having a regular bedtime does help
and a regular wake-up time
also helps good luck two fan
at mortaza underscore mq
says is social media responsible for
sleep disorder
in most of the cases i'm gonna say no
but i haven't done the research as a
scientist i'm going to go ahead and
remind you that
most of means more than 50
social media can do two things that can
interfere with your sleep
one is it can keep you up later at night
than you should be
it can make you have too much
interaction with
light before sleep because you're
checking it before sleep
the most important thing that social
media probably interferes with
sleep through is filling your head with
all sorts of information a lot of which
is probably not necessarily useful
the human brain has not changed in the
last 10 years versus hundreds of
thousands of years of evolution
we do need a lot of downtime and we do
need boredom and social media has kind
of removed
our ability to have downtime and boredom
which are good for the brain and also do
contribute
to healthier sleep notorious omg
with a heart at secret diary mom what's
the best time of day to switch from
uppers to downers
asking for my neurotransmitters well
secret diary mom
your neurotransmitters pretty much know
what to do without you adding
anything to them so i would say
stop drinking caffeine after noon or
one or two o'clock that's an upper and
in terms of downers
i hope you mean nap time and meditation
thanks secret diary mom
iman at why not iman underscore
says being tired all the time is such a
mystery
is it anemia vitamin d deficiency
chronic fatigue syndrome
depression insomnia is it just the
crushing weight of being alive in a
capitalistic society
someone cure me please well i'm going to
go for
crushing weight of being alive in the
capitalistic society
but there are tests for anemia for
vitamin d deficiency
we do have a way to assess if you have
chronic fatigue syndrome
depression and insomnia those are likely
because of the crushing weight of being
alive in a capitalistic society
so i'm tired all the time too phoebe
luckhurst at phoebe luckhurst says can
anyone please help with some insights
into what games like candy crush do to
your brain
all my neuroscientists are rejecting my
advances well
phoebe this neuroscientist isn't
rejecting your advances
i'll be happy to tell you they're
filling your brain with
random pieces of candy that you have to
i don't know make rows of so they
disappear
candy crush is wonderful for distraction
it is mindless fun
it's like candy it doesn't really have
any nutritional value
but it sure feels good when you put it
in your mouth and eat it
in all seriousness candy crush is asking
your brain to do
a lot of non-challenging computation
while also distracting you from anything
that's going on in reality which means
like any good drug or bad drug you
should use it for good and not
evil good luck ale salgado
at tiempo asm says should we use drugs
to boost brain power
what do you think neuroscientists have
different posture well this
neuroscientist has terrible posture
i'm just kidding i'm actually a little
bit on the fence here about boosting
brain power with drugs
i think that what worries me about the
discussions i've heard surrounding
boosting brain power
is a need to increase productivity
beyond
what feels human and humane and i think
that's something that concerns me
i don't think that brain power should be
seen as something that
can and should be treated as if we're a
computer that needs to be supercharged
i think that there's a human interest
level of understanding that the power
that we have
is what our brains were developed to
have
and on the other hand we have the
ability to create drugs that can enhance
that and are there safe ways to do that
i'm not sure right now it seems that
it's being abused but i think more will
be revealed
rhiannon at v4 nuisance
says wait i have a question okay i'm
waiting i'm not trying to offend anyone
just curious are things like
schizophrenia ocd
dissociative identity disorder etc
considered
neurodivergent i've seen people define
it as your brain being wired differently
so does that apply to those as well just
wanted to know thank you
smiley face neurodivergent typically
refers
to people whose brains learn differently
and it's something we typically use kind
of in academic circles
to talk about modalities for learning
and helping people achieve to the level
that their
brain is happy to achieve at things like
schizophrenia ocd
dissociative identity disorder those are
examples of the brain
not necessarily being wired differently
but we do know that there are
there are genetic differences for some
forms of schizophrenia
and ocd did is usually
that there's likely a genetic component
and also environmental impacts
but these are things that are more about
the way you are genetically coded rather
than the notion of being
wired differently so i like to think of
neurodivergent as
wiring in terms of learning and those
other things in terms of diagnostic
psychiatric
criteria ravi at
shria ravi 12 says does tic toc
stimulate
alice in wonderland syndrome i couldn't
possibly be the only person who feels
like they're suckered into a bizarre
time value warp
when i'm consuming this media form i'm
impressed that you're calling tiktok a
media form
i'm digging that alice in wonderland
syndrome is is
typically the syndrome where you feel
that a body part of yours
is of a different size it's a visual and
kind of sensory perceptual syndrome
the notion of being kind of down the
rabbit hole and losing time is
maybe a looser definition of alice in
wonderland syndrome and
i would say you're absolutely correct
things like
tick tock and those kinds of media forms
do
absolutely suck time away and much like
video gaming
you can pass a lot of time without
knowing the time has passed
so you are absolutely right tick-tock
makes you feel like
time goes away dr koch
at red stocking lady says head hurting
from caffeine withdrawal
or growing dendrites caffeine withdrawal
will absolutely make your head hurt
it'll also make you really really grumpy
growing dendrites which are the uh the
extensions of neuronal processes that
communicate with other neurons is
not typically something we feel but if
you're quitting caffeine your dendrites
might be really really grateful
since caffeine's not so great for your
brain especially in large quantities
so it could be your dendrites saying
like you've abused us for too long we're
going to make your head hurt
as we stretch ourselves out sieva
says what increases the possibilities of
multiple sclerosis
does smoking marijuana break down axons
multiple sclerosis is a genetic disorder
which does cause the demyelination of
axons axons are the things that connect
the cell body to the parts of the cell
that communicate with other cells
and they are lined axons are lined with
essentially fats why we need to eat fat
and cholesterol
but in multiple sclerosis this fat
starts to break down
and the axons can't communicate
information rapidly because
fat is a great insulator for moving
information quickly
especially of an electrical quality
smoking marijuana
does a lot of things it cannot break
down axons
it also does not demyelinate axons which
is what happens in multiple sclerosis
so multiple sclerosis is a genetic
disease
and smoking marijuana does a lot of
things to interfere with brain function
but breaking down axons is not one of
them
faithy at fpxox says am i now realizing
the reality of life
because i just turned 25 and my frontal
lobe just finished developing
or is it the four months of quarantine
your frontal lobe does finish developing
somewhere in your early 20s but that's
not really what makes you understand the
reality of life
you won't really understand the reality
of life until you can't leave your house
and you have to wear a mask anytime you
do
and you're stuck with yourself and all
of your problems and issues
so i'm going to vote for quarantine
happy birthday
bewilde beast at alex underscore alex
is a nerve cell the long thin one with a
huge head with loads of dendrites
there are lots of different kinds of
neurons and they look a lot of different
ways
but the classical nerve cell the
classical neuron is
a long thin one with a huge head that's
where the nucleus is with the dna
and loads of dendrites those are the
things that communicate with other cells
so yep you got it
that's a nerve cell hull house and
medium
titty goth says why don't people talk
about how having add
and adhd can apparently cut around eight
years off a person's lifespan
and being untreated undiagnosed until
adulthood can apparently cut an
estimated 13 years off your lifespan
because your development is so stunted
during childhood to be honest with you i
have not heard these statistics
and this is something i would like to
look into i think it's an important
point though that
a lot of times in science we have
correlations that may not be
causations so with these kind of facts
and this is kind of
the dangerous thing about the internet
we can hear things and kind of run with
them
but it really takes looking at this kind
of study and what factors did they
control for
what are the other comorbid factors we
were dealing with in
in understanding who the sample size is
so i'm going to look into this
and thank you for bringing it to my
attention these are very very startling
statistics and i'm very curious so
scientists are always learning too eve
at eve dehaan says does anyone else who
gets sleep paralysis a lot
know what triggers it won't have it for
like six months and then have it for
like five days in a row
sleep paralysis is pretty much what it
sounds like it's usually when you're in
a half sleep state
and your body cannot move you often have
cognition
meaning you want to move you are not
asleep
it's not a dream it's somewhere in
between and there have been studies done
showing that the brain waves are
literally kind of caught in between
it can be very very terrifying very
scary i would look into
what's going on in terms of maybe
speaking to a therapist
or a cognitive behavioral therapist to
see if there's a correlation
there may be food triggers environmental
triggers
and sometimes a cognitive behavioral
therapist can
give you words and cues that can help
you come out of that state quicker
and good luck waning
says you know how you can reboot devices
yes juani i know
do you think it's possible to do that to
the human brain if not
why well this is going to be an answer
you don't like
there is something called
electroconvulsive therapy treatment
and many view is very inhumane
and i would tend to agree with all due
respect
it is essentially a reboot for the human
brain
and it involves passing large amounts of
electrical current into the brain
it is a really really dramatic treatment
usually
for untreatable suicidal depression that
is
unresponsive to many many other
modalities
i have known people who have had this
done it is very significant should not
be taken lightly
in general i will say therapy is a
wonderful way to re-parent your brain
and to reboot emotionally it is not the
kind of reboot i think you were asking
about
that one guy at that one guy 21 000 says
how do people with epilepsy handle
police lights
epilepsy is a neurological condition
that
does involve seizures those seizures
can be brought on by strobe lights
flickering lights
probably been in a movie theater or a
show at an amusement park where they say
if you have epilepsy this show involves
strobe lights police lights are not
you know vibrating at that frequency is
kind of the
hippy dippy way to say it police lights
do not trigger epilepsy
to my knowledge it's usually a more
specific and high frequency
kind of flickering that's going to
trigger that robert at
blk rocket says are mammals wired for
empathy grief
compassion loneliness well robert
you and i are mammals and i'm pretty
sure you know that we are wired for
empathy
it's one of the things that helps us
stay bonded as
mammals and perpetuate the species if
you think about it
we are wired for processing grief yes
primates in particular are wired for
grief
we absolutely see cases of really most
mammals being wired for
compassion and for altruistic behavior
as for us being wired for loneliness
loneliness is an extension of the need
to connect
and perpetuate togetherness
even non-mammals are wired for that but
yes
mammals are wired for all of those
things and more
i really enjoyed answering this
smattering of neuroscience support
questions i think that
the format of social media makes us able
to communicate
in ways about things we're curious about
and for someone who studied the brain
for 12 years of my life and continues to
be a science educator
it's beautiful to talk about these
things it's beautiful to see
really the holes in people's knowledge
and also what they're curious about and
what's bothering them
it really underscores for me the need
for us to have more access for mental
health
and i think also people are interested
in the brain because it's fun and
amazing and that's the reason i studied
it so
super happy to talk about that with
anyone who wants to talk about it thank
you so much everybody for your questions
stay curious and maybe we'll do this
again sometime
ciao